Hey youtubers, it's Charlie! This is going
to be my Jessica Jones Episode 5 through 8
video. Really freeing the David Tennant beast
all over the computer screen or however you
guys have been watching. He really is fantastic
as this villain. Seriously, purple man on
Jessica Jones is way better than he is in
the comics just careful for spoilers on Jessica
Jones through episode eight so were basically
starting with Jessica before kill grave all
the way up to the point where she does what
would Jessica do she takes into that special
cell favorite moments from this block episodes
were the hot dogs save me like Jessica dressed
in the hot dog costume before kill grave saving
the little girl who walked into the middle
of the street kill grave in the police station
when the phone rings and he loses his ship
next person whose phone rings has to eat it
and I think the most epic.moment is when hope
finds out that she's pregnant with kill grave's
baby tries to induce an abortion by having
the other prisoners beat her and they went
up themselves when Jaron Hogarth takes the
fetus to try an experiment on it secretly
moment a fetus snatching probably the most
eft up things happen in the series so far
that's really what the series vacillates between
kind of funny tongue-in-cheek eft up moments
in like really oh my God holy should eft up
moments there are a couple moments in this
block of episodes where the plot drags just
a little bit like the energy really goes crazy
in episode five we get some Captain America
avengers Easter eggs which is like once you
go out to the big green guy or the flatware
like you see the little kid running the Captain
America costume the woman here you might recognize
from friends she kinda goes after Jessica
for being super powered people blaming a lot
of the collateral damage from the avengers
battle with the should Towery on anybody with
powers Jessica's like that wasn't me man go
after the big green guy in his squad so you
probably recognize that the big thing with
the series is showing how people deal with
their trauma for better or for worse the ideas
the Jessica that the lead of the show has
really shady relationship with herself in
one of the beasts quote unquote that she has
to slay by the end of the series include including
kill grave he's like a physical beast that
she has displayed is that she has to slay
a lot of for mental demons are family time
when she was a teenager not her fault all
the people around her dying when kill grave
is there not her fault kill grave abducting
her the first time when she tried to be a
hero not her fault so that's actually a bigger
demon for display I think the kill grave himself
like there is some big stuff that happens
after episode nine got the save for another
video but but she essentially she searched
jumping over these big mental hurdles like
slang some of these demons but the big arcs
early on R1 trying to get kill grave the first
time her first attempt to take them down she
doesn't try to get Luke Cage's help they have
trouble working as a team and he goes terribly
then there's a Luke Cage arc with him finding
out about how his wife died in splitting with
Jessica like hurt her blaming herself from
that do you wonder if he was actually going
to kill that MTA guard before she came clean
she's like he didn't do it he didn't do it
I killed your wife but is eft up as she treats
herself kill grave always finds a way to one
up her in be like the most messed up person
on the show he buys her childhood house and
then goes through it meticulously making it
look exactly like it did when she lived there
seriously he said that he took a magnifying
glass from pictures that he got from a realtor
to find the stack of CDs in her room to make
it look exactly like it did when she lived
there but actually when she is at her childhood
home living with kill grave like that whole
sequence one of the most fun moments is hurt
trying to get kill grave to use his powers
for good and I think he's being completely
100% honest when he says you need to stay
with me because I don't know the difference
between good or bad seriously I thought it
was a good idea to have that man shoot his
face off she kinda realizes that he is not
like she's like ship so she has to ponder
the question of whether or not she can use
his powers for good is it worth it having
to live with him and sacrifice the rest of
her life just a circle back around for some
of the biggest comic book Easter eggs so there
is like a hero's for higher moment when she
and Luke Cage team up then we see the jewel
costume from the comics that's her actual
comic book superhero costume from when she
almost became part of the avengers calling
out some big flaws in superhero costumes nowadays
they had to call me camel to if I wore that
whenever a female actress has to wear a swimsuit
or anything that's really revealing using
the easy fix for camel toe is gaffer tape
is crazy as that sounds that's an old Hollywood
trick people actually do that but they did
change some things about how Jessica ran afoul
of the purple man the first time but she saves
her future roommate on the street is being
mugged and Killgrave walks up in his like
oh my God look at you you're fantastic so
what happened in the comics this is the Jessica
Jones intervened at a restaurant altercation
and it just happened to be the purple man
does a similar type of account in the comics
but happen inside a restaurant and it was
not her future roommate that she was trying
to help the interesting thing about her breaking
free so like in the TV show it kind of shows
that she slowly develops an immunity to the
virus that he admits but in the comic she
only broke free when the avengers helped her
what happened is is Killgrave sent her to
kill daredevil but she ran in the Scarlet
witch mistook her for daredevil tried to kill
her but the avengers teamed up and beat the
crap out of her and then saw what was going
on and try to help her for better or for worse
if you've read the purple man in the comics
he does do more terrible things like the things
that he does are much much worse for you probably
agree that David Tennant's version is a much
more fully formed character there's more of
an actual person there it's really fascinating
to learn why he is the way he is which actually
doesn't happen so little bit later in the
series will talk about that when he gets like
my episode 9 to 12 video because it is absolutely
fascinating what happens in episode nine is
my big question if you guys let me know in
the comments what were your like favorite
funny moments from episodes four through eight
and what was like the most messed up thing
for you I think we can all probably agree
that the dead fetus was probably the most
messed up moment finding out that Jeri Hogarth
was like hey you know I wanted to say that
if you can as me making this video I'm only
at about episode 10 so there's still like
a ways to go most of you guys that I've seen
commenting who already finished the series
do say that you like the way it and so I am
looking forward to the big finale if you guys
have finished the series and you big questions
or comments about stuff that happens after
episode it just please use spoiler tag's in
the comments was can happen later tonight
is there's a new episode of Doctor who episode
10 a whole bunch of WTF stuff happens I'll
be posting a video for that in a couple hours
my next Jessica Jones episode video might
not post till Monday just because there's
a whole bunch of stuff happening on Sunday
give like Game of Thrones, Walking Dead my
next Jessica Jones episode video might not
post till Monday just because so much is happening
on Sunday the new Game of Thrones and new
Walking Dead so just be sure to subscribe
to get everything if you guys haven't seen
it yet I posted a new Flash / Arrow crossover
trailer were I name the reverse flash ring
giveaway winner so i'll put a link in the
description just just in case you haven't
seen it you can click here for the link to
that flarrow trailer I do the reverse flash
ring giveaway whole bunch Hawkman Hawkgirl
Vandal Savage stuff going on and you can click
here for all my Jessica Jones episode videos.
thank you so much for watching, everybody
high five and I'll see you guys tonight!